[Musique]
qui parmi vous ici pense qu'il a pas
assez de temps régulièrement il se dit
j'ai pas assez de temps enfin les choses
dont j'ai besoin par level pas relevé de
la main ok donc on va garder maintenant
les mains les main levée je vois des
gens qui ont de main levée par billie
jean que les mâles avaient vont baisser
la main toutes les personnes qui
regardent la télévision régulièrement
ok mon pc la main les gens qui vont sur
facebook régulièrement on sait plus on
paie c'est la main les gens qui
regardent des séries télévisées
américaines régulièrement hockey dont
ils rêvent plus beaucoup de gens
j'espère vous avoir convaincus que vous
mentez d'accord quand on dit qu'on
manque de temps en fait on ment je m'en
suis rendu compte en fait parce que dans
mon quotidien justement je l'accompagné
recruteurs et j'ai des recruteurs qui me
font ce retour qui est nicolas on n'a
pas le temps de répondre aux annonces
pire encore j'ai comme au retour on n'a
pas le temps de recruter vous images et
des recruteurs qui vous disent on n'a
pas le temps de recruter donc j'essayais
de comprendre qu'est-ce qui voulait
vraiment dire par on n'a pas le temps
sachant que le temps est le même pour
tout le monde barack obama et beyoncé
ont autant de temps que vous on peut pas
économisé le temps ou pas le partage est
donc le temps ce n'est pas une donnée
qui peut se manquer du coup j'essaie de
comprendre qu'est ce que les gens
voulaient vraiment dire j'ai fait ma ma
propre enquête scientifique et j'en suis
venue à une équation alors qu'elle
paraît goût reuze qui vaut ce qu'elle
vaut
c'est que en fait le temps c'est égal à
la priorité fois l'énergie
une fois la concentration pourquoi une
multiplication c'est pour vous dire que
dès que vous avez un facteur qui tombe à
zéro tout le reste tombe à zéro
avec la priorité la priorité c'est quoi
vous avez toujours autour de vous
quelqu'un qui vous dit j'ai pas le temps
de faire du sport
qu'est ce que ça veut dire j'ai pas le
temps de faire du sport tas veut dire le
sport n'est pas ma priorité
d'ailleurs c'était mon cas a pendant
longtemps depuis le 2012 je répété j'ai
envie de faire du judo mais j'ai pas le
temps j'ai envie de faire du judo mais
j'ai pas d'argent j'ai envie faire du
judo et un jour je me suis j'ai été
honnête avec moi même en me disant qu'en
fait j'avais pas envie de faire du judo
ma priorité c'est plus de passer deux
heures sur facebook tous les jours que
d'aller au judo et c'est là le problème
aussi que la priorité c'est qu'on est
tous de mauvaise foi avec la priorité on
a envie d'avoir envie
on a envie d'avoir envie d'être
quelqu'un qui fait du sport et vous
pouvez avoir tout le temps que vous
voulez moi j'ai eu quatre ans j'ai pas
fait une goutte de judo parce que ce
n'est pas ma priorité
deuxième point c'est l'énergie
qu'est ce que j'ai appelé l'énergie vous
savez moi une priorité là actuellement
c'est travailler sur mon blog et qu'est
ce qui se passe tous les dimanches
matins je me dis je vais travailler son
blog à la fin sur la même chose j'ai
passé toute la journée sur youtube dans
mon lit pour nous donc est simple c'est
que j'ai pas l'énergie solaire autre
chose que de rester dans mon lit on pas
c'est pareil si vous avez le temps la
priorité mais vous n'avez pas l'énergie
vous n'allez nulle pa troisième point la
concentration et là on va faire une
petite séance de thérapie collective
c'est un petit peu compliqué on va tous
une fois pour toutes
oubliez l'idée qu'on puisse faire
plusieurs choses à la fois alors je sais
qu'il ya des gens qui pensent que les
hommes peuvent pas que les femmes
peuvent
c'est faux aucun être humain ne peut
faire plusieurs choses à la fois ce que
vous appelez le multitâche en fait c'est
votre cerveau qui va très vite d'une
tâche et une autre est comme ça a très
vite la surchauffe ça vous donne
l'impression d'être productif évidemment
vous l'êtes pas d'où l'intérêt de la
concentration
il ya un concept que vous invite à
regarder qui s'appelle le flou la zone
qui est justement l'hyper concentration
qui fait que quand on est très très très
concentré sur une tâche on peut faire en
un jour ce qu'on pourrait faire une
semaine et d'ailleurs
jamais je vous demande et de rompre une
vitre avec vos mains vous irez pas
mettre des coups de poing au hasard sur
la vie tout apeuré toujours au même
endroit d'où l'intérêt de la
concentration donc passé mon équation
manque de temps égal soit manque de
priorités soit manque d'énergie flamande
de concentration si vous manquez d'un
seul des éléments vous aurez pas le
temps encore pire si vous manquez de
tous les éléments et ce qui m'a
intéressé sur l'équation c'est que j'ai
trouvé un outil de productivité
justement qui permet de booster
l'équation
alors je préfère de suspense puisque le
thème il est connu c'est le jeu en fait
le jeu va booster votre équation quelque
chose qui est amusant vous avez plus de
priorité
plus d'énergie plus de concentration non
seulement ça mais en plus le jeu à trois
effets bénéfiques que j'ai que j'ai que
j'ai analysé première effet bénéfique
c'est que l'apprentissage est plus
rapide avec le jeu tout ceux et celles
qui ont joué à 10 ou adibou le savent on
apprend plus vite en s'amusant
d'ailleurs la même manière quand j'étais
petit j'avais pas à retenir la table des
neuf et en fait je l'a appris en
m'amusant parce qu'il ya une une astuce
et vous prenez vos doigts vous faites
par dante 9 x 3 ou pas c'est le
troisième doit vous avez 27 de douala
cette douala pour garder ralentissait
pas compris mais lol une fois que vous
avez compris des super simple et c'est
comme ça que moi je retrouve la table de
la gelée jamais vraiment apprise mon
premier effet du jeu deuxième effet
bénéfique du jeu c'est que le jeu vous
permet de dédramatiser les choses j'ai
marqué un point commun parmi les gens
qui sont performants je parlais avec mon
collègue récemment qui me disait que moi
tu sais nicolas en tant que commercial
j'ai commencé à être bon le jour de ce
rendu compte que c'était un jeu
le jour où je me suis rendu compte que
les noms je les prenne pas
personnellement qu'en fait sur neuf non
j'aurai un oui que si j'appelle 100
personnes j'aurais dit oui dont je
m'amuse la manière j'ai rencontré
quelqu'un qui me disait dont l'instant
formation charme à dire de recruteurs
qui disent ah bah c'est marrant avec des
techniques de messages un peu plus
rigolo un peu plus marrant plus humain
quand on écrit aux gens eh ben je le
vois plus comme un jeu et je suis moins
frustré j'ai plus envie d'aller crude à
l'écrire au candidat est derrière
exemple que j'ai observé récemment
c'était une coach de retour à l'emploi
qui me disait c'est nicolas le
qui fait vraiment la différence dans le
retour à l'emploi c'est le jour où
j'arrive à leur faire admettre et c'est
compliqué parce qu'évidemment le chômage
est une expérience qui est très très
compliqué mais à se dire voilà je vais
dédramatiser c'est un jeu l'entretien
c'est un jeu la lettre de motivation
c'est un jeu et une fois qu'ils ont
compris ça ils ont beaucoup plus
performant donc voilà pour les pour les
deux premiers effets troisième effets du
jeu c'est une fois vous savez qu'il ya
un jeu ça veut dire vous pouvez tricher
je parle de triche au sens positif
moi je suis un grand défenseur de la
triche le je déteste rechercher deux
appartements c'est un truc qui
m'exaspère pour plein de raisons
la dernière fois que j'ai été obligé de
chercher un appartement qu'est ce que
j'ai fait j'ai analysé les règles du jeu
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait
l'endroit où ça bloquait c'était
toujours les visites avec 15 personnes
pour visiter enfin ça sert à rien je me
suis dit je optimiser mon temps j'ai
appelé alors je vais appeler beaucoup
plus mais c'est sur ma chaise non c'est
pas grave mais je vais l'accepter de
visite et que les appartements je suis
le premier et le deuxième à visiter du
coup c'est ce que j'ai fait et j'ai eu
éviter deux appartements j'ai eu deux
propositions le toit en 48 heures en
contournant les règles vous voyez vous à
l'e3 est bénéfique du jeu pour vous
pouvez observer et là on arrive sur un
effet encore plus bénéfique qui est
souvent négligée souvent a tendance à
opposer le sérieux et le jeu opposé le
travail et le jeu de vous dire
aujourd'hui a rien de plus sérieux que
le jeu le jeu est une affaire
extrêmement sérieuse
pourquoi parce qu'en fait le jeu un
autre effet bénéfique c'est qu'il nous
protège d'un des poisons les plus
mortelles de l'humanité j'étais
récemment elle a dans une station de
métro qui s'appelle filles du calvaire
la bien nommée
je ne savais pas quoi faire de mon temps
dans le métro j'ai envie de d'optimiser
mon temps justement de ne pas perdre mon
temps donc qu'est-ce que je fais j'ai
toujours un livre j'ai toujours de quoi
écrire un article et trois fois sur
quatre il se passe quoi je fais rien je
pas d'énergie dans le métro je suis sur
la porte n'est rien donc j'étais en
train de rien faire quand des enfants
sont arrivés une quinzaine d'enfants
sont arrivés et ce qui était marrant
c'est que eux ne s'ennuyait pas il joua
au bras de fer chinois il s'accrocher au
bar du métro ils sont
n'est pas pour elle vous dit ça parce
qu'au final les enfants ont compris
quelque chose c'est que l'ennui est un
des éléments les plus délétères quand
vous réfléchissez à votre équation de
temps d'énergie de priorité de
concentration si vous vous ennuyez ça à
faire descendre toute l'équation est
l'ennui temps ce qui est extrêmement
douloureuse et les enfants la ville
encore plus douloureusement que nous
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il refuse de
s'ennuyer
pourquoi il est venu plus tôt le
heureusement parce que je pas si vous
savez mais le temps passe plus lentement
quand vous êtes enfant alors mauvaise
nouvelle ça veut dire que le temps
s'accélère quand on vieillit c'est
pourquoi parce que relativement une
journée pour un enfant de 8 ans elle
prend dix fois moins de place qu'une
journée pour qu'un cas 80 donc les
enfants comprennent très intuitivement
qui doivent sur l'ennui effet c'est ça
qui fait que il
ils fuient intuitivement 7,7 source
d'ennuis et qu'on a oublié nous moyenne
presque que j'adore d'une chanson qui
dit ce qu'ils appellent être adulte
c'est commettre l'adultère tromper
l'enfant qui est en toi pour devenir ce
qu'on t'a dit d'être et c'est un peu ce
qu'on fait tous c'est à dire qu'à un
moment dans notre vie on accepte que
dans le monde professionnel on va
s'ennuyer quand vous demandez enfin ce
qu'ils veulent faire quand ils sont plus
grands et vous disent astronautes ils
vous disent pompiers et ils finissent
vous responsable de marketing ou
formateur parce qu'on s'est contenté et
c'est là l'autre l'autre chose que vous
de vous partager c'est qu'au final la
procrastination c'est à dire le fait de
remettre les choses au lendemain c'est
moi j'ai un g1 jus très atteint par sage
et un slogan c'est ne remet jamais à
demain ce que tu peux remettre à après
demain le la procrastination pendant
longtemps j'ai cru que c'était mon
ennemi mais ce n'est pas le cas la
procrastination c'est un signal c'est
pas un ennemi ja pas jusqu'à dire si
votre ami laisse un signal quand vous
procrastiner ça veut dire que votre
enfant interne comprend que vous n'avez
pas envie de faire ça de la même manière
le manque de productivité n'est pas une
anomalie c'est normal traîner des pieds
c'est pas une anomalie c'est normal
c'est un signal et souvent les gens
prennent les choses à l'envers moi et
moi le premier a pendant longtemps je
cherchais des méthodes de productivité
et en fait on prend le problème
totalement à l'envers c'est à dire que
en traîne des pieds
on va me dire la productivité c'est
comme si quelqu'un de vous voir en vous
disant écoute nicolas
j'ai besoin de faire paris lyon mais la
dernière fois je les fais en deux mois
commence à deux mois ça prend deux
heures en tgv nord mais je les fais à
reculons et à cloche pied ce que je peux
aller plus vite à cloche pied
oui si vous résolvez pas d'abord ce
problème dans vie sert à rien de vouloir
être productif à mort alors pour finir
justement quand vous réfléchissez à tout
ça déjà le jeu des blocs l'ennui des
blocs l'équation bout de votre énergie
votre priorité votre concentration on
l'a vu si jamais vous est plus ou moins
convaincus aujourd'hui vous allez
arrêter de dire j'ai pas de temps pour
ça vous dirait j'ai pas la priorité pour
ça j'ai pas l'énergie pour ça j'ai pas
la concentration pour ça
peut-être mieux encore peut-être que
vous allez vraiment dire maintenant j'ai
pas envie de jouer à ça ce qui est
marrant quand vous observez les enfants
quand ils ont plus envie d'interagir
avec un autre enfant et vous dise je
joue plus avec lui j'ai plus envie de
jouer avec lui alors malheureusement
mauvaise nouvelle le jeu ne faut pas
décréter que c'est un jeu le jeu n'est
pas un jeu dans l'absolu par exemple le
football c'était un jeu pour certaines
personnes
c'était un calvaire pour d'autres de la
manière s'il a déjà entendu parler du
mythe de sisyphe 1,7 y y et condamné par
les dieux a monté d une pierre et à la
redescendre à la remontée à la
redescendre indéfiniment ça fait une
corvée c'est une punition
et pourtant quand vous regardez les
enfants jouets font pareil ils prennent
une balle il ajoute et prennent une
balle il ajouté après une balle il
ajoute à définir mais il s'amuse parce
que c'est eux qui ont décidé de jouer
nous tient vraiment cette notion de ce
que j'étais c'est de jouer est ce que je
m'amuse
il ya quelque chose que j'ai remarquée
parmi les les personnes souvent les plus
talentueuses qui qui m'entourent c'est
qu'elles ont toujours le même la même
orientation carrière elles me disent tu
vois là j'ai fait ça parce que même
musée là j'ai arrêté parce que je ne
m'amusais plus
même chose à écouter juste votre enfant
interne qui vous dit à un moment là
n'est plus en train de s'amuser là t'as
plus envie de faire ça le plus souvent
mais les enfants ont une sagesse qu'on
oublie je sais pas pour vous mais en
tout cas je me suis beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup amusé à partie son
mari goût elles préparées merci à tous
et à toutes
[Applaudissements]